hola hola buenas tardes cómo están todos
mucho gusto ya me presentaron mi nombre
es de boras rosales y pues bueno yo les
vengo a hablar hoy sobre el sentido
común el menos común de los sentidos
y bueno normalmente cuando nacemos todos
tenemos cinco sentidos que los conocemos
la vista el gusto el olfato el tacto el
oído e inclusive pues hay personas que
desarrollan más un sentido que otro en
el caso de los músicos pues tienen más
desarrollado lo que es el oído por
ejemplo en mi caso tengo como más
desarrollado el tacto entonces sí a
veces platico con usted es decir los
agarro no piensen que estoy ligando
simplemente es que soy una persona que
tiene desarrollado más ese sentido e
inclusive también en mujeres hablamos de
un sentido este se puede decir como el
sexto sentido que va muy asociado con la
intuición sobre todo cuando a veces
existe una pareja y esta pareja no se
engaña dicen así es que mi sexto sentido
me lo había dicho
pero pues realmente qué es ese sentido
común o qué es lo que les vengo a
platicar el día de hoy en el sentido
común va asociado con este conjunto de
creencias
también conocimientos y también la parte
que tiene que ver con un tema cultural
el cual nos hace actuar de una manera
determinada se puede decir que una
manera correcta dictada por las normas
sociales ante una situación por ejemplo
el sentido común me hace que en un
velorio en lugar de decir felicidades
pues dé el pésame no eso podemos decir
que podemos aplicar ahí el sentido común
sin embargo el concepto de sentido común
a mí me gusta más este concepto que es
como sentido común es la lógica no pero
también tiene que ver con la atención y
querer hacer las cosas bien y ahorita
más adelante les voy a comentar por qué
es querer esa atención o el hacer las
cosas bien y pues bueno aquí hay una
frase que les pongo no el sentido común
todos lo tenemos es algo con lo que
realmente vamos haciendo vamos
desarrollándolo pero pocos se aplican y
creo que tiene que ver también con un
tema como cultural así por llamarle como
decía la definición esas creencias esa
cultura en méxico no se ha quedado vamos
creciendo ya qué edad se pierde el
sentido común vamos a la verdad no lo
logró como descifraron un poquito y creo
que tiene que ver cuando llegamos una
etapa obviamente de la adultez a donde
tenemos como mayor obligaciones mayores
tareas mayores cosas que realizar
entonces ahí vamos este se puede decir
que llenándonos de juicios y prejuicios
no entonces este sentido común a veces
ya no están como no y también tiene que
ver con lo que les decía la atención a
ver vamos a aquí a preguntarles
rápidamente cuando ustedes se levantan
que es lo primero que hacen cuando se
levantan
ahora sí que la mano quien checa su
celular que es lo primero no todavía ni
siquiera abren los ojos bien y luego
luego agarran el celular empiezan a ver
redes sociales contestar mensajes
correos quien hace eso en la mañana a
ver levante la mano ok muchas manos la
mayoría no y porque son pocas las
personas que cuando se levantan dicen
agradecen al mundo no agradece ok estoy
bien me siento bien hoy no descanse o
amanecí con este dolor o estoy al cien
realmente no se disfruta el momento y
cuando de repente nos estamos bañando y
todo ahí la la gente esté estamos
pensando en otra cosa no estamos
pensando a la mejor camos a desayunar o
qué le voy a decir los problemas que
tengo en la oficina en los problemas
personales que voy a contestar no
estamos viviendo el momento cuando vamos
manejando lo mismo súper peligroso no
estábamos haciendo todo menos manejando
vamos hablando por teléfono vamos
testeando vamos a este también
maquillándose en el caso de las mujeres
entonces no estamos aquí y en el ahora
llegamos al trabajo y de repente el jefe
pide el
proyecto no lo pide lo que no se encargó
el trabajo y dice oye pero yo no lo
quería en este formato no lo quería en
word no lo quería a la mejor en power
point no es así se le va a presentar al
cliente en unos minutos que no tenías
sentido común
y hacerlo en un formato en el que se
debía de hacer y tú la gente a lo mejor
tú lo piensas y sage que payaso no o que
payasa
pues no realmente no lo pensé oa la
mejor no fuiste claro en tus órdenes o
en lo que querías comunicarme no y la
otra persona sus argumentos es dt lo
dije muy claro te lo puse por correo y
no lo hiciste entonces ahí en una
persona estaba comentando que no se está
aplicando el sentido común
y esa es una realidad
y realmente porque no tenemos como como
este sentido común
la presentación pero no tenemos esa
adopción de una filosofía budista que
nos habla de aquí y el ahora no todo
como dice esta frase todo lugar aquí y
todo momento es ahora realmente créanme
que el pasado por más actitudes que
hagan hoy no va a hacer que cambie algo
porque ya pasó y el futuro es incierto
entonces aquí parte de ese sentido común
es realmente estar enfocados en el aquí
y en el ahora
ahora bien ya platicamos por qué se da
esa falta de sentido común sobre todo en
la parte adulta ahora voy a comentarles
qué podemos hacer para incentivar ese
sentido común
el número uno y creo que es algo que
impacta no solamente en el ámbito
personal o en el ámbito laboral no en
cualquier actividad hay que tener esa
empatía realmente cuando nos ponemos en
el lugar de las otras personas te cambia
no antes de hacer algo de brindar a lo
mejor un producto un servicio
como esa persona le gustaría recibirlo
como esa persona
pues realmente lo quieren o qué es lo
que está buscando
y aquí ojo la empatía también nos ayuda
a centrar en que nosotros no conocemos
un trasfondo de esa persona no no
sabemos que a la mejor llegó enojada
porque esa mañana no tenía luz no se
pudo bañar no tenga agua caliente había
mucho tráfico chocó entonces no sabemos
todo lo que trae esa persona entonces
simplemente antes de actuar antes de
hacer una acción vamos a darnos unos
minutitos un paso atrás y sentir esa
empatía por la otra persona
el punto número 2 que les digo hay que
dejar de seguir estereotipos no vivimos
ahorita en un mundo en el cual existen
muchas mujeres maravillas existen muchos
superman y pues realmente
este muchos dicen hay que yo soy
múltiples que no puede hacer muchas
cosas a la vez
si los puedo hacer yo creo que eres como
en uno en un millón no tienes el cuerpo
calloso muy desarrollado porque
realmente eso es falso
puedes hacer muchas actividades pero
créeme que ninguna la puedes hacer con
la misma efectividad o que realmente
estén bien hechos entonces es mejor
centrarse en lo que estás haciendo ok
ahorita estoy aquí y lo que voy a hacer
lo voy a hacer de la mejor forma posible
no necesariamente
recuerden esta frase no importa la
cantidad importa la calidad y también va
aunado a lo que ya les había comentado
esta filosofía budista de centrarse en
el aquí y en el ahora es súper
importante no a veces cuesta trabajo por
lo mismo de las actividades y el día al
día pues nos va llevando en en una ola
no y esta ola a veces se va haciendo más
grande pero realmente tomarnos el tiempo
de decir lo que sí voy a hacer esto lo
hago y ahorita es el momento de hacerlo
el punto número 4 que de hecho me gusta
no ayer está leyendo un artículo de
google que decía que esta empresa no va
a contratar a nadie con títulos
universitarios bueno hay que estudiarlo
sí hay que estudiarlo pero las empresas
y más de ramos tecnológicos ahorita
están viendo a personas con skills que
uno solucionen problemas dos que
realmente sean personas proactivas
que esté que no les tengas que estar
diciendo cómo hacer las cosas sino que
las personas salgan por ellas y tres que
tengan sentido común entonces ahí ojo de
tarea lo que ahorita las empresas es lo
que están buscando en este ámbito
laboral
y el punto número 5 que creo que también
a lo largo de estas pláticas y que
tienen que ver la mayoría con temas de
emprendurismo es la parte de la pasión
algo que tú haces te gusta
créanme que si lo haces con amor te va a
salir bien y no es cosa de que necesites
o a veces no tener sentido común o si
realmente te gusta lo que haces pones
atención te concentras de focalizar las
cosas sale me salen porque saben
y bueno el sentido común por eso les
comentaba que es la lógica es la
atención es hacer las cosas bien y yo
los invito a ponerla en práctica ahora
así que no nos cuesta nada
incentivar ese sentido común para lo que
hagan se necesita y más para temas que
tienen que ver si quieren emprender en
este mundo y sobre todo hay que
reinventarse no como lo dice el evento
pues muchas gracias yo los dejo y espero
que les haya gustado mi plática gracias